the call was for a million-person March
and many in Baghdad heeded the appeal
from influential Shia Muslim cleric
moqtada or southern his message is
simple all Americans out the March was
also backed by other Shia groups
including kathai Hezbollah whose leader
al mahdi al Mohandas was killed
alongside Iranian general Qasem
Soleimani in last month's US missile
attack - if it's not on a heart this
gathering you see today are al
Mujahideen they're the forces that will
expel the occupiers the resistance
groups today showing the American
occupiers we are united as one body and
it is real and despite some differences
in point of views we unite as one whip
the protest was joined by people from
all over some there are a dozen our land
our goal is to expel all the occupiers
we are standing for Iraq against an
intervention we want dignity and we want
sovereignty the governments divided an
internal that should find it difficult
to ignore such a large protest
anti-government protests since October
have already fought Prime Minister are
deluged Almaty turn ounces resignation
he remains as caretaker pending a
replacement leader and new elections the
Americans have said they're determined
to stay in Iraq and at the invitation of
the Iraqi Prime Minister one of the more
popular songs of this protest movement
is this one the chorus goes swimmingly
on it what's a million now regardless of
whether a million people are here or not
Bakara al Sadr has managed to send his
message that he wants the US troops out
of Iraq and he's got this kind of
support behind him in Braun card al
jazeera
Baghdad well there was another big
demonstration in the Iraqi capital and
our correspondent Osama bin Javaid was
at that one it was held in Tahrir Square
and that is the place of course which
has been the center of the
anti-government process have been being
held for months despite a crackdown
people say they are not going away
Amnesty International coming out a few
hours ago saying that 600 protesters
have been killed that is something that
activists have been telling us
here as well in Tahrir Square saying
that the government numbers saying less
than 500 people have been killed are
very no more people have been killed
25,000 people have been wounded since
October and people have been coming here
for months
witness are a mother and daughter who've
been coming to the protest for the last
few months
zeyneb and fatima thank you very much
for joining us and now tell us what is
the point in you coming here you've seen
a lot of death and destruction does
there not scare you and what is the
point in your presence in Tahrir Square
honestly I am scheduled a come here I
come here thinking that maybe I won't
return home
maybe I'll return home without night
without LED no one knows when they come
here I help out the pharmacist sometimes
for mother helps cooking but seeing
everybody here especially the young boys
helping us and fighting and putting
their life for death all for us for a
better country for a better world
honestly that just gives me empathy and
I need my human rights
I need basic human rights so I come here
fighting for my human rights I had
enough and it is enough honest and I'm
putting my foot down to the government
it's enough that there is any clean
water there are bad hospital the doctors
don't appreciate you yeah there's just
no basic human rights we don't have
electricity I go home I'm tired I want
heat there's no heat I go home and
freezing I have to take a blanket and
put myself around two three blankets
because there's no electricity due to
the government not thinking about us